hey youtubers it's Charlie so surprise
Game of Thrones bonus video HBO
confirmed all of samwell's family for
season 6 so I'm gonna do is just like a
quick rundown on the cast and then I'll
do a history for house Tarly and I'm
just gonna go ahead and start a new
round of the giveaway now so all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
it's a Amazon gift card and careful for
spoilers for everything through season 5
on the show if you haven't seen it yet
so here we go starting off with
samwell's father randyll Tarly now he's
been mentioned briefly on the show
mostly Samwell talking about how he
loves his other brother Dickon more than
he loves Samwell the Santa's
complemented Randall - Sam saying that
he was an amazing battle master even
though he fought against Stannis during
Robert's rebellion the actor that's
playing him is named James Faulkner you
may have seen a month out Nabi or maybe
da Vinci's demons pretty much all the
bad stuff that Samwell has said about
his father is dead on so just expect him
to be the most hardcore disappointed dad
you've ever seen next to Tywin Lannister
on the flip side of that Sam Will's
mother very soft very caring awesome mom
her name is Melissa Florence she liked
the rest of samwell's family also hail
from the reach you guys have heard about
Dickon because Samwell said my father
loves my younger brother way more than
me just speaking about martial pursuits
he's someone in the vein of Jaime
Lannister let the Sun that most powerful
fathers wish they would have only you
know much much less twincest he's being
played by Freddie stroma who most of you
probably saw in Harry Potter and then
they cast a sister that's being played
by Rebecca Benson now there's only gonna
be one sister on the show and I don't
recall seeing her in anything else so
she's kind of a fresh face but it seems
like his family is actually gonna get a
pretty substantial arc especially
especially in and around Old Town when
Sam ball it goes to train to be a
maester now most of you know they're
from the reach they rule over horn Hill
that's where their ancestral home is in
their bannermen of the Tyrells for now
it seems like most of their scenes are
gonna happen in and around that area of
Westeros but there are things in the
books that suggests that randyll Tarly
might come to King's Landing eventually
but if you have read the books just
please use spoiler tags if you want to
talk about why you think that is now
rewind back to season 1 if you remember
the only reason that Samwell joined the
Nights Watch is so there wouldn't be an
issue with the succession inside his
family his father randyll Tarly wanted
Sam's younger brother Dickon to inherit
his title and he couldn't do that
because Sam's the older brother unless
Sam joined the Nights Watch
most of the history associated with
house charlie just goes back to Robert's
rebellion that's you know most of what
George R Martin has wrote so far the big
event that randyll Tarly is associated
with the one that everyone Revere's him
for is for pushing Robert back at the
Battle of Ashford now if you remember
Ashford is actually a pretty important
place in the history of A Song of Ice
and Fire
because that's where the Duncan egg
series picks up is it a tournament in
Ashford so everything continues to be
connected but the funny thing is is that
mace Tyrell actually took credit for
that wind and didn't give it to randyll
Tarly so I'm interested to see if they
show some saltiness between those two
people
mace Tyrell isn't quite the fool in the
books that he is on the show they kind
of combined mace Tyrell with a couple
different Tyrell characters so they
might just forget about any old wounds
between them in the books
the only other really big thing of note
about the charli's is that they have the
ancestral Valyrian blade hearts pain
that's been passed down through their
family I know you guys are always asking
about which houses have Valyrian blades
there are very few of them right now
where we are on the storyline that still
had them a lot of them had been lost
over the years I think I did a Twitter
post when I name them all but just
expect randyll Tarly when you see him to
have a beautiful-looking blade some of
you guys have had some really good
questions about Samwell becoming a
maester just that particular zuv that
because becoming a maester is actually a
pretty complicated process it's like
going to school for a degree it takes a
long time and we only have three seasons
left I think the TV show has like two
big options they could go with one they
could just compress his studies it's a
smaller amount of time just you know use
TV logic to they could just have him
leave the Citadel early after getting
specific information but not becoming an
actual maester like not completing his
chain the most important stuff he needs
to know right now is how to defeat White
Walkers in the Citadel has one of the
best libraries in the world so that's
the best place to go maester or no
maester way before the purple wedding
Tyrion actually went to this little
looking for books on dragons but there's
also another big library in old volantis
and there's one in a Shai where MELAS
Andrews from way way far in the east
there's just so much that he has to do I
have no idea how long he's gonna stay in
Old Town but you know before he comes
back to the wall hopefully he'll stay
there all season just because I feel
like they'd really shortchange the story
if they were to speed that along too
much we all feel like Jon Snow's coming
back so shits going down to the north so
Samwell isn't needed right
now we'll be much closer to White
Walkers reaching the wall and that's
really when you need Samwell with all
the knowledge you guys let me know
though how long do you think that the TV
show is gonna keep Samwell down in Old
Town studying at the Citadel obviously
there's gonna be a lot of drama with his
family but how long do you think it's
gonna take him to find the knowledge
that he's looking for let's not forget
about the added complication of Gilly
and her baby with his family that's
gonna be such an awesome family reunion
it seems like most of his family not
including his dad is relatively
accepting so the probably like okay this
is interesting you have a wildling woman
in her child with you they'll probably
try to form like a protective circle
around Samwell and Gilly so that randyll
Tarly can't run him through with hearts
bein made no mistake randyll Tarly
amazing Battlemaster
but he is every bit as hard as Tywin
Lannister and just to talk about some of
the other castings too so Ian McShane
still unconfirmed but it seems like he
might show up as part of the gravedigger
storyline a lot of people think that
he's gonna be like the Septon mayor bald
character just because that might be
potentially spoilery I've already done a
video about the gravedigger theory and
how the Hound might be coming back so
I'll put a link in the description if
you want to learn more about that but as
of right now it seems like that's where
Ian McShane is gonna show up as part of
that storyline and because I'm posting
this video now I'm probably gonna push
my northern houses video til next week
I'll do a QA on Sunday I'm just you know
moving all these videos up just a little
bit so while you guys wait for all that
stuff you can click here to learn all
about the gravedigger theory and how the
Hound might be coming back still very
much unconfirmed and you can click here
to learn all about the duncan egg saga
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you